so we've already heard from the
government about the household side of
their energy package now we've heard
about businesses and it could also be
quite expensive here's how it works
though this is showing you wholesale gas
prices so what you pay for prices in the
market for day ahead gas prices you can
see they were relatively low uh back in
2020 just look at what's happened since
you know that is the energy crisis writ
large what the government is going to do
essentially here is to put a cap on it
so essentially guaranteeing a price
above which you don't have to pay and it
will pay the difference between that and
whatever the market price turns out to
be but here's the thing look at where
the market price is expected to go in
the next six months really high and the
aperture is given that the government
has to pay the difference well we all do
taxpayers that could well mount up over
the course of the next few months let me
just see how far it could mount up bring
it over there put it on this axis about
25 billion pounds based on the current
uh futures curve for gas prices it's
worth saying that this is the price of
the furlough scheme over one year so it
gives you a sense that was really
expensive but this is also expensive we
know already that the household scheme
is going to be really expensive again on
futures market prices up to 70 billion
pounds a year that's for one year this
is six months so if the government
wanted to extend that by another six
months look that comes up to 50 billion
pounds you know you're talking about
serious money here and remember that
actually runs over two years so we need
to double that
if that were going for two years you're
talking about 100 billion there 140
billion there that's almost a quarter of
a trillion pounds on these two schemes
alone of course it all depends on what
happens with market prices going ahead
and no one knows what's going to happen
there but even so a lot of people
getting nervous and the bank of england
which is poised to change interest rates
at its next meeting tomorrow well at the
moment there's where interest rates are
back in february they were expected to
peak at about 1.5 percent this is
looking out over the future years so
that's in this february that's where
they thought they were going to go but
look at how things changed over the
following months in august
investors thought they were going to
peak at 2.75 percent
just recently just a few days ago look
at that investors now expecting interest
rates to peak at 4.75
partly a consequence of the fact that
the government is spending a lot more
money and inflation is so high this is a
massive change and we may well see one
more step in that road for households
and businesses across the country in the
next bank of england uh meeting which is
coming up tomorrow maybe 0.75 change in
interest rates